While plenty of your favorite movies actually
get the critical acclaim and box office success
they deserve, there are some amazing films
that just don't seem to click with an audience.
Still, just because a film wasn't a box office
success at first release doesn't mean that
it's not worth your time.
Here are some genuinely great movies from
this decade that bombed at the box office.
Free Fire
British director Ben Wheatley, who made the
modern horror masterpiece Kill List, quietly
dropped Free Fire in 2017.
Hardly anybody saw it, but Free Fire has got
all the makings of a cult classic.
The film is a lean romp that takes place almost
entirely inside a single warehouse.
Free Fire tells the story of an arms deal
gone wrong, leaving all the lowlifes involved
trapped with nothing but their wits and a
whole lot of guns to get them out.
It's filled with offbeat humor, one-liners,
and physical comedy that nicely breaks the
tension here and there.
"Hey Vern, is everybody like you where you
come from?"
"Vern is a rare and mysterious jewel.”
Tomorrowland
A fun, exuberant, and inventive science fiction
tale, Tomorrowland was one of the better science-fiction
films of the last 10 years.
The film features George Clooney as a reclusive
genius inventor who meets a science-crazed
teenage girl.
Their adventures center around Tomorrowland,
an alternate dimension of scientific wonder.
Full of twists, turns, and some compelling
sci-fi concepts under director Brad Bird's
expert direction, Tomorrowland deserved to
be a huge hit.
Scott Pilgrim vs. The World
There are movies that fail at the box office
that are only guilty of being released a few
years too early, and it was clear from the
first trailer that Scott Pilgrim vs. The World
was ahead of its time.
Director Edgar Wright chose to ramp up the
comic book and video game influence on the
story all the way to 11.
Bad guys explode into piles of coins and sound
effects appear written out on the screen.
It's a self-aware and self-referential film
winking at the audience constantly and packed
to the gills with nostalgia for classic video
games.
If released in today's age of metatextual
pop culture, the film probably would have
been a massive success.
"Hi.
Big fan."
"Why wouldn't you be?"
Popstar: Never Stop Never Stopping
A fake documentary spoofing concert-biopics
of modern pop sensations should be a onenote
journey with a few good jabs about Instagram
culture and autotune at best.
Instead, Popstar: Never Stop Never Stopping
turned into one of the best mainstream comedies
of 2016.
Created by comedy music group The Lonely Island,
the film stars Andy Samberg as Conner, a Justin
Bieber-esque pop star on the rise.
It's got plenty of laughs, but what's more
surprising is how much heart is hidden beneath
its many celebrity cameos.
Unfortunately, it underperformed at the box
office, but we think time is going to be kind
to this one.
"A nun dunks a basketball, living the impossible,
a man breaks his leg inside a hospital.
We just thought of that and it could change
the world."
Dredd
Lean, relentless, and running at a breakneck
pace, Dredd is a viscerally satisfying sci-fi
action film adapted from the long-running
british comic series Judge Dredd.
The film sees future super-cop Judge Dredd
and his trainee, Judge Anderson, trapped in
a massive skyscraper with hundreds of armed
thugs out to kill them.
Leading the gang of criminals is Ma-ma, a
notorious drug dealer played with ruthless
relish by Game of Thrones’ Lena Heady.
The film is a violent, brutal romp, taking
Dredd and Anderson up through the building's
many floors in increasingly inventive action
sequences.
"This block operates under the same rules
as the rest of the city.
Ma-Ma is not the law.
I am the law."
Premium Rush
An action-crime story set in the world of
fixed-gear bike messengers shouldn't work,
and yet somehow, Premium Rush is fantastic.
Premium Rush is anchored by the excellent
Michael Shannon, who really shines in his
role as a crooked cop.
As he relentlessly pursues Joseph Gordon-Levitt's
bike messenger character throughout New York
City, the film showcases some killer chase
sequences and well-edited action scenes.
The film's nonlinear narrative seals the deal,
making Premium Rush a whole lot of fun and
very much worth your time.
Warrior
The story of two brothers separated as teenagers
who find themselves forced to fight one another
in a mixed martial arts tournament sounds
cliche at first glance, but Warrior is surprisingly
powerful.
The brothers, played by Joel Edgerton and
Tom Hardy have gone down different paths since
their separation but are perpetually tied
together by their alcoholic screw-up father.
Warrior is very much Rocky for the UFC generation,
and the movie packs the same emotional punch
of Sylvester Stallone's seminal classic.
This is one you shouldn't miss, but make sure
you bring tissues.
You'll need them.
"You're not the only one who's suffered Tommy.
I didn't even know she was sick."